[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits
I'm Linc and I'm Rhett this week at the
round table of dim lighting we are
exploring the question is privacy dead
and do we even care
Wow Wow it could get philosophical it
could get intimate how private are we
going to get you know what kind of price
are we talking about here I don't sorry
I mean what how public are we gonna get
about our private it's privacy about our
privacy yeah let's jump right into it
jump jump jump it all started good
morning by the way
good morning they recording this one in
the morning now but you already knew
that when you looked at my face and or
listen to my voice which is a my voice
gets a little bit lower it starts a
little bit lower and then by the by the
end of the day you talk like Mickey
Mouse yeah a lot of times you don't you
can know we never record after 4 p.m.
because he's full Mickey Mouse by that
point it's it's kind of like counting
the rings on a tree yeah yeah listen
I've been awake for 12 hours listening
to my voice over the course of the day I
don't know physiologically that's
happening there it's like a sundial more
than tree rings they're stretched it
lets you know what time you're not
stretching they're constricting cuz
tighter vocal cords would make higher so
everything on me gets tighter over the
course of the day Oh like I hop out of
bed and it's everything's pretty tight
and then I you know I loosen up pretty
quickly and then it immediately starts
getting to it again it's just like
slowly turning the guitar knobs
what are those knobs called tuning knobs
so I said let's let's jump right into it
and that's what moisturizers for though
if you do a full body moisturizer every
30 to 45 minutes you stay loose all day
don't you know when I step out this talk
speaking of privacy when I go into the
loft you're lotioning I go into the
lotion loft the lotion lock there's a
lot more conjecture about what's in our
loft after the elk at where the money
man's men went up there
they they came back now what they did
well they know but they're not allowed
to say hello Alex was bloody again that
goes back to the privacy so so this this
might get heavy or it might not but
that's a teaser it might get scary i I
I'm I'm I'm curious it safe but I am
gonna get scared because I've avoided
this question actively I just don't like
to engage mentally and things that I
think will make me have to change my
life and my practices or more
importantly make me more anxious I don't
know I I don't need to I don't need to
get tighter than I already am London
today I would I'd sound like a chipmunk
right that's even worse than Mickey
mm-hmm it all started because my
doorbell was broken okay when I bought
the house that we have lived in for
years the doorbell worked but what I
didn't really understand was that the
doorbell was it was just a it was your
remote doorbell it wasn't
what's that that's too much clicking
that is that your no are you hitting one
spacebar again and again that was his
elbow he's got tennis elbow okay now I
feel like I have to apologize for
putting you on the spot
Jacob Jacob say who it was and Jacob
they're hitting the space bar again and
again I'm trying to talk about my damn
doorbell it could have been anybody that
that is a you're exactly right when
people would press my doorbell that's
what happened it'd be like pressing the
spacebar with the computers off well I
mean I think I may have talked about
this before but many times in the past
few years that you've been living in
this house I've showed up at your house
rung the doorbell and I didn't hear
anything and then started to beat on the
door and then beat on the window and
then I start trying to figure out how to
get into your backyard because you know
I'm in there and you know that I'm
expecting you most right because you're
like breather at 8:30 and now then I am
matera you know oh we didn't hear it
here because it didn't work it causes
problems first of all there was a 24 to
36 month period
you defended the doorbell you're like
well it usually works but a doorbell
that usually works doesn't always work
yeah it's the time that it doesn't work
that is worth paying attention to
and if you got a package that needs to
be signed for and then they walk away
with it
forgettable now it's now it's impacting
me brother now you got to go to the
shipping center this is not just or fill
out some form ticking off the person at
the front door this is taken off the
person on the other side of it or me and
they're beating you beating on my
beating on my window and stuff it's like
you break my window down man I'll loosen
it up you've gotten you've gotten
legitimately angry at my doorbell or me
I got legitimately angry at you I don't
get angry at an intimate object that's a
lie I get angry at the people behind
them so when you when you in highschool
were taken out of the basketball game
and you kick the bleach I wasn't mad at
the blue matter there's a ridiculous
assessment right you am a data coach no
you were mad at who Rhett I was mad at
yourself the coach you broke your cage
you broke your toe then I was mad at
myself so I was mad at myself after I
broke my toe all of this was a was a
ruse just to get you to admit that night
you've got you still got some baggage
you bring it up at my anger issues from
age 17 so I decided I'm gonna get a
doorbell and I heard about I mean
there's lots of doorbells on the market
I got the nest thermostat not a sponsor
and I saw some an advertisement for the
nest doorbell I think it's called hello
I can't remember but it's a it's a it's
a camera that then when somebody rings
it even if you're not at home you can
see on your phone you can see a video
and you can talk to him and if you know
if it's if it's a burglar
again I'm not trying to sell this thing
they sold me on it and I bought it and
this is the same functionality of the
ring doorbell but a different thing
company right yeah different company
okay I'm a fan of the nest company I
would love for you to be a sponsor but
subject to this conversation that we're
gonna have today because I go on the
website to buy this doorbell
and you know I get excited because it's
like oh now it's on my phone and this is
no normal doorbell this is like it's
also a security camera and it's a
communication device for people at the
door and I just seems fun and cool and
safe and neat but I go on the website
and all of a sudden I'm like hold on
they're not they also sell some some
outdoor security cameras and there's
been some burglaries in my neighborhood
mm-hmm I'm like I got to get with the
program
I had sunglasses stolen from my own
driveway from the car in my own driveway
one time and that's disconcerting that's
a violation of privacy they'll get into
it did they just open the door they just
opened the door yeah it was unlocked
hmm rummage through it probably some
kids kids wearing my prescription
sunglasses ha joke's on you kids unless
I needed him let's have the same exact
eye condition that you did that would be
serendipitous if you knew that the
person who stole your glasses had the
exact same eye condition as you what
does it make you feel better about them
it redeems the entire situation you're
like a Robin Hood well and well I'm not
no not really but you know I'm still the
king but so then I start putting outdoor
security cameras in my McCart and then
I'm like you know I at this point I
frequently asked what would Rhett do you
try to bracelet this is it Rhett was we
start buying everything I can I sell
those I'm trying to loosen up a little
bit and by buying more things because
I've been so I have a purchasing problem
meaning you have a problem purchasing
that's your purchasing brother I know
this doesn't sound healthy but me
deciding to buy things is therapeutic
yeah
do you agree by the way I know it sounds
crazy to many no I mean the knower yes
do I agree that you have a purchasing
problem do you agree that it's
therapeutic for me to buy things yes you
should spend more money so I did that
yeah and then I saw that they had indoor
cameras indoor outdoor front door which
I know you have one of those I was like
let me get one of those and then I'm
like well if I'm gonna get one and I'm
starting to think where I'm gonna put
I'm like why should I need three so
about three
so I bought a outdoor cameras three
indoor cameras and a doorbell side note
I I added on the installation of the
doorbell which I probably could have
done myself and the guy comes out to do
it and then the reason why I have a
remote doorbell is because the it's not
wired it doesn't work so the new
doorbell would not work and it still
does not work because I haven't called a
proper electrician to come out and
install wiring for a proper doorbell
which the nest doorbell will be so
that's not even functional at this point
neither are my outdoor cameras who had I
bought weeks ago because I just haven't
gotten around to putting those things up
take some work drilling of holes from
the outside to the inside of your house
and you're doing imitating hey no yeah
well I'm gonna I'm gonna hire an
electrician to do all of that because
but I'll kill myself somehow with
electricity or wires so I as you know I
am doing the same thing but I'm doing it
I've got a guy who's doing the whole
thing can I can I talk to him but you're
making me think maybe I should because
they're talking about putting a literal
DVR in my house well ten different
cameras I'm going with ten cameras yeah
I see you you see the difference between
us I'm bragging about I bought three
cameras I thought I was doing something
is that well I've got tip that's your
problem
I'm making your prop by treating my
problem making yours worse you don't get
ten cameras just cuz I got three no I
didn't know how many cameras you're
getting the guy came over but well my
contractors doing some other work on the
house who has a guy who just did his
house he's like he just walked around
the house and he was like you need one
there and you should have went there and
you said went there and then are you
said and done he's like you need ten
counties nest cameras cuz cuz they they
store either five hours or days worth of
footage in the cloud and it's not stored
locally I don't want to get into this no
but no but yeah I mean you're making I'm
thinking out loud here because then a
guy could just break in and take the DVR
well don't put it at the front
door well it's not like I've got it like
don't make it the welcome mat yeah but
if you know that somebody's got cameras
you see the cameras and you be like oh
this is a DVR house or a cloud house
right now I gotta get the DVR backed up
on a cloud I've all the only thing I
have installed is the cloud I don't have
anything sent well actually I do because
the only thing I have working are the
three indoor cameras I got those set up
but what about when your Wi-Fi goes down
that's a problem huh you know what
that's all I got to do is unplug your
router and then do the dirty business
too late I've already recorded you and
it's already been sent to the cloud bro
a bit gotcha yeah
but neither way are you facing my house
right now yeah pretty much in it and am
i comfortable talking about all this on
a podcast I don't know you brought it up
I mean by telling people that you're
gonna have this incredible security at
your home I think that this is this
would be a deterrent well here's the
thing
all of a sudden now that I have these
here's what I'm get it I've got these
three cameras set up inside of my house
ones looking at the kitchen ones looking
at the living room well tell people
where they're looking at because then
that robber will go to their other rooms
well that's why I've got ten camera they
see yeah you cannot get away from my
cameras that that that's overkill by the
way that is stupid amount of cameras
because if you can pass any I wanted to
be like well it's like they can teleport
into any room and bypass I wanted to be
like one of those rooms you're being in
a bank usually by a security perfect
like Mission Impossible we get to like
right go through lasers yep I got so
many cameras that you cannot you're
always being watched
you're being bamboozled man it's like
1984 in my house at all times and we've
decorated the whole house like 1984
ripped off but you need to come to grips
with something that I have been smacked
in the face with which is the ethical
dilemma of indoor security cameras
because here's what happens I can pull
up my phone I can look at my house right
now I can look at anybody in my house I
can also listen I can also talk to them
through the cameras let's do it
no I'm not gonna do okay does attest
nobody's at my house right now I did it
right before cuz you just [ __ ] and
awesome awesome I performed a test with
Christie which I'll tell you about she's
not home right now so I can't do it
do it live but I started to feel weird
when the first night we had it I'm going
to bed that night and of course it's a
new toy so I pull up Chris he like leans
over and Mischa what are you doing I'm
um I'm like I'm looking at my cameras
and like get one in the bedroom no oh
this is for posterity I don't send that
one to posterity what do you mean it's
for posterity so I can watch myself
that's not what posterity is posterity
means that but just my technique what
what you seem to be commenting when you
say for posterity what you're implying
is I have all youtubes you know what I
do commentary okay on myself you know
why that not really YouTube when you're
dead and gone you will relay that your
estate will release this footage from
your bedroom as you say it yeah well no
when artwork for the people to benefit
from nobody gonna benefit from when both
my wife and I die whoever dies first
of course when we're both dead then we
released the sex tapes and just come out
and say it
yeah yeah I was hoping you wouldn't just
come out and we ate we sell it so for
this so the kids can have a future yeah
in it yeah that is just reams and reams
of it that's a great word choice I'm
glad you picked up on that take a little
breather here so I'm in I'm in bed
pulling up my nest cams and it just so
happened that that night my kids had
friends over for sleepover right and
there and I'm like I'm like look they're
in the kitchen they're eating something
oh and then I'm like they're having a
conversation and I'm like I turned it
off I'm like yeah you made the right it
doesn't seem right all of a sudden when
I bought the thing I just thought this
is cool these cameras are cool and then
it's like you know is it could be a pet
cam or obviously it can be a security
camera if someone breaks into your house
but isn't I mean just just so I'm on the
right page
because the way I thought about this is
exclusively about the security of my
family in my home I have it but I
thought but well I haven't been thinking
about what your time is it's it's not
but you're thinking about it was this is
a pet cam first and foremost so you can
look at Jade during the day well we have
friends who she's gonna be a little
black dot on the screen man well it's
not gonna be that intimate we create her
when we're gone because she's a Datsun
which means she sneakily pees everywhere
she have a crate cam no put an s camp
right on the crate you want to get a
close-up so I don't even need it as a
pet cam I don't know why I bought these
cameras because having security you need
a you need a siren you need a alarm but
you gotta have one of those two if not
one of those the reason why you have
cameras is to catch these boogers and in
jail them like get a facial
identification of these people yeah so
it's not it's not as much about safety
as it is about justice and I could be
wrong about that you can talk on it say
hey get out of my house and they'll part
they'll run away it's a deterrent so
people see that you've got added
distraction cameras go to the house that
doesn't have any camp again if they see
all ten of them it's too late
but you I got Tim because typically
they're gonna like shoot out the cameras
they've only got eight bullets and I
also there's two cameras that are still
there I also justified the camera as my
kid my kids are of an age now that
sometimes not every time but given
certain circumstances week Chrissy and I
can leave the kids alone at home you
know I mean Lilly and Lincoln are
responsible to take care of themselves
in lando right same is true at your
house right yeah so but it's nice to
know you can kind of check on them and
see what's up and there's a level of
accountability there but then with this
with this voyeuristic power I started to
become a little disconcerted with the
ethics of it now
and I'm the only one who has access to
it like Christie hasn't asked for it yet
and I'll gladly teach her how to do it
it's just one of those things like
download the next step and but it's
pretty easy but she just hasn't done it
yet
right so here I am the only one who
isn't gonna be violated my privacy but
um I'm still kind of wigging out about
this thing trying to figure it out so I
think these are the questions that I'm
wrestling with that then I do believe
lead directly into a much larger
question when you because it's
applicable to the entire digital world
that we live in and that we type in and
that we operate in that we live our
lives in and we're being surveilled and
advertised to and manipulated judge dot
dot dot how were told to control how far
does this thing go so these are the
questions we seek to answer starting
with should I get rid of my indoor
cameras okay I have a strong opinion it
can wait until after the break because
we want to let you know that you can
grab not only the t-shirt that I'm
wearing
not only sure that looks like the shirt
that link is wearing but is not the
shirt that he's wearing it's better
because it has miniature horses or a
woodgrain on it but you can grab these
ear biscuits jars which are in short
supply we're not ever making them again
and they are running low inventory low I
turn on the camera to the warehouse and
I counted them you know right those got
you should let me tell you what those
guys in the warehouse we're doing when I
the first time I looked at the camera
shipping jars yeah right anyway your
biscuits jars a lot of other stuff get
them until they're gone because when
they're gone they're gone so ever
mythical dot store thanks for supporting
into entertainment so if we have a
babysitter come over yep
I feel like here you go we have to
disclose there are cameras here would
you agree with that yes and then I mean
how do i how do we feel about that I
mean it's like when I I think that's
okay because we're hiring somebody to do
a job and I like that there's an added
level of accountability that like
Chrissy and I are out on a date or maybe
we're good you know maybe we're do
something overnight so it's like an
extended period of time we can just
check in and see what's up and like
there's a sense of accountability at any
point we could be watching mm-hmm it is
a little creepy but it's a professional
relationship where you're paying
somebody to do a job we have cameras
here for security purposes but it's
totally legal because it's a it's it's a
business where these things happen now
we don't monitor our employees in that
way for accountability but we could we
could legally right and I guess that
applies at home too I shouldn't say
guess I'm I assert that that's the truth
but but I do feel like I need to
disclose that but what about we got
friends over or my kids have friends
over should I should I put up a poster
that's all I could just a disclosure
that like once you enter this premises
it's like here in LA you walk into
places all the time there's like big
placards that say you will be filmed if
you enter this establishment yeah you
showed one of those on your front door
Chris you'll love it okay well I'll tell
you what I think my policy is gonna be
big when I get these ten now maybe I'll
go 12 cameras I don't know okay and then
I'll then I'll tell you what I the
experiment I performed like I've on my
wife Wow was it related to the cameras
or we're just talking about well it
depends on what you're about to say okay
so I think that the obviously like I
said the primary purpose of the cameras
in my mind is to serve as to protect the
not the privacy but the security to
ensure the security of my family and my
belongings and so therefore it is
primarily a deterrent because anyone any
would-be booger as you said is going to
see that there are cameras there's going
to be cameras on the outside there's
gonna be cameras on the inside a total
of 10 and and then I think that the
secondary purpose is in the case of an
incident it is a record like you said
for identification purposes for me that
is the sole purpose of the cameras
now I do think that you should tell
anyone anybody who's watching your kids
you should be like yeah we've got
cameras
anybody who's a friend usually you're
gonna be in their presence if it was a
friend who was coming to like house it'd
be like hey there's cameras just so you
know I would probably also say the next
part of my personal policy which is as a
rule I do not randomly review the
footage or watch the footage for
entertainment or voyeuristic purposes
just so you know the purpose has to
trust me on that
the Purdue have to trust me but the
purpose of the cameras is for
surveillance is a deterrent and then a
record but but not so I guess not for
constant surveillance then i of my
family or friends or anybody who's
legally in the house now in the case
where there is some sort of incident
okay
for instance the other day I get a call
from Lindsay he was watching the kids
and sometimes and does some stuff for us
and she's like Shepard and Locke just
had a pretty intense fight there was a
punch I mean there was a punch from
Shepard to block clock it's not gonna
punch Shepard a 10 year old punching a
14 year old yeah it was Halloween candy
incident because Shepard had a lot of
Halloween candy lock didn't have any and
you just wanted a piece and that turned
into a fight a punch and a punch to the
face that drew blood oh okay there
McLaughlin's this cut from where the lip
of the nose the nose Oh God yeah you
know you can what piece of candy was
this I don't know you don't even know
really butterscotch footage or not
exactly so now in the case that there is
a discrepancy in their accounts of the
of the event oh yeah
then I feel like in those cases I will
have every right once these cameras are
installed to review the tape did you
review the tape no I have they're not
installed yet oh dang it they're gonna
be installed any day and
that's the thing you want for
entertainment purposes you want to see
you know Shepard punch luck right yeah
and so I would do it out of curiosity
yeah I would watch it but I would also
be like you know I might coach Shepard
on his technique or I might just say
it's in the hips I think I might say
guys listen this is ridiculous look at
what you look at yourselves listen and
look at what you did
showing them anything like when a kid
pitches a fit when a kid is being a
typical ass like they can be sometimes
or maybe when I'm being an ass oh yeah
Jesse could say yeah a lot of times
she's like you said this I'm sure of it
oh yeah we can go to the tape so to me
argument settlement again I haven't
employed this yet because I don't have
that I don't have it in my house but to
me that is the only time in which we can
go to the tape when the see the involved
parties if it's to adults if it's me and
Jesse I think we both have to agree that
we're gonna go to this we're gonna go to
the tape
uh-huh if if it's the kids I have the
right as their Guardian to go to the
tape when I want to but I'm not gonna be
like okay one of them has friends over
and I want to see what they're getting
into and that's about one of them has a
girlfriend over and I want to see what
they're getting into at that point I
think the fact that there are cameras
will probably serve as a deterrent
knowing that you there's not a corner of
my house you can go through that you're
not you know under surveillance which is
actually not true that's not that's not
the case but I'm not going to tell you
where the secret corners are but my kids
will know and just knowing that there's
cameras there they're gonna behave a
little bit differently but they're also
gonna know that guys I'm not spying on
you there's not one of their bedroom you
know right right so anyway that's just
where my general philosophy that I've
been thinking about well I'm like I'm
glad you said that because now when
Chrissy and I get in a heated
conversation a disagreement I'm gonna be
like can we move this conversation to
the kitchen where we've got a camera on
top of the fridge you know let's just
that's true cause a lot of those I mean
I want to do that those arguments and
discussions happen in the bedroom and at
that point you don't have
right I mean you don't have but you do
for put it here right you know I thought
about buddy system season two because
this is actually a source of conflict
between our two characters because it
was discovered that you had surveillance
of me the top bunk yes just a camera on
the top bunk and then the other camera
cameras that looked at the other cameras
you're probably that camera extremely
don't laugh at our own joke it was good
I mean when we came up with that I was
like this is great again buddy system
freaking watch it
start with season two don't waste your
time yeah you don't have to watch both
seasons but if you watch if you choose
to watch one season season one I'm proud
of season one to watch the second season
you don't need the first season to just
dip right into the second season and get
there just jump in you know we worked
our characters work through it so can we
but I felt my character felt very
violated and I just it's one of those
things where well you know I logged onto
the thing this morning well know
yesterday I was I was out with Lily and
I was just like you know I gotta get
into the habit of looking at the nest to
see what's happening at home again I
have the opposite mindset that you do
why do you need to get in the Hat why
didn't have it for what I just like it I
like know I was a weird position exactly
I'm just being honest so I turn it on
and I'm like nobody's in that room
nobody's in the kitchen oh there's the
living room okay
there's lando sitting on the couch he's
on if he's on Christie's phone oh and
there's Christy she's that she's taking
a nap
on the other couch I'm like okay that's
good information now I'm not gonna call
or text Christy because I don't want to
wake her up
see but you're and then well but I
didn't say anything or let them know
that I was looking at them and it felt
weird and then today I was like you know
what we're about to have this
conversation I'm gonna do it one more
time to see what happens I don't even
know if Chrissy's at home and I looked
and there she was
standing in the kitchen just doing some
just start naked she was she was doing
someone she's got to leave the house and
then I said I turned on the microphone
and I said oh gosh and I saw her kind of
look around a little bit she looked down
she didn't know that it came from the
upper corner of the bookshelf like in
the near the ceiling in the other room
and then Jade like runs over and I'm
like hey and J starts freaking out and
then Christy walks over and looks at the
camera and I didn't have I couldn't hear
her for some reason because it wasn't
connected then I called her on the phone
later I was like hey I'm do I told her
why I was doing it for a podcast not
just because I'm peeping tom and I said
even though I do have a practice that I
guess it may have a problem but I said
how did you feel and she was like well
it felt weird
I mean yeah I I'm not doing anything
that you know it's that I'm embarrassed
about I'm trying to hide but it did feel
weird that all of a sudden you were
watching me and I immediately thought
how long has he been watching me right
you know and that's that feels like a
violation you know it if something feels
weird you feel a little violated you
know your personal privacy because so I
don't know what to do
I actually I mean is it about me using
constraint or is about me taking the
cameras down well okay so you heard what
I thought my philosophy was gonna be it
was to not do what you did as a general
rule but I am open to changing and maybe
one is better than the other it seems
right now that just given our general
understanding of privacy in modern
society that it's a wiser choice to not
randomly check in on people right but
some of the research but here's the
thing well I like sometimes if Christy's
not at home if I know she's out and I'm
like I know she's coming back I could
text her but she's driving and I can
just look she's enabled location
services on her phone so I can look on
my phone under the text screen and see
where she is see where her phone is well
of course there of course you can argue
so into the vet feels and that feels
okay conveniences and the functionality
of because she willingly shared them of
this monitoring my location horizon
which we're gonna get into that but I
think that there if we take a look at
where we came from you know like intern
are basically the historical
understanding of privacy is a pretty
fascinating thing and then what is our
current understanding of privacy and
then where are we going in the future
and I think we might be able to land at
what our policy should be okay yeah
let's let's do it
so again this this goes well beyond
security cameras this is all types of
privacy this is just the concept of
privacy which in which basically informs
the way Christie feels about you
checking in on her because she is a
product of modern society as is except
for the vampires everyone who's
listening so this is a this is an
article from medium which you know
anyone can write an article on medium
but there's there's a guy Greg fair
enstein who has this thing called the
fair and steam wire which was a very
well researched and I've only looked at
this article but basically pull from a
lot of different sources to kind of go
through some historical examples of
tracking the way we think about privacy
which I think we can camp out on any one
of these that that we want to okay but
interestingly and I will be when it
sounds like I'm reading yes I am just
quoting Greg so I'm not trying to sound
like Greg I am quoting him privacy as it
is conventionally understood is only
about 150 years old okay so most humans
living throughout history had little
concept of privacy in their tiny
communities and obviously the further
you go back and the closer we get to
diverting off of a common ancestor from
chimpanzees about 6 million years ago
the less and less privacy mattered the
privacy has become more important sort
of as we've advanced but you get like
the picture of being in like a hunter
gatherer community and just the idea of
I got to go somewhere to do
this thing was just not really in fact
we see this in there's there's modern
societies that have been observed that
not matter but basically tribal people
who have not been influenced by modern
society there's a few of them that are
still study contemporary contemporary
hunter-gatherer communities in fact
Jared Diamond who wrote one of my
favorite books ever Guns Germs and Steel
is a UCLA anthropologist
he said because hunter-gatherer children
sleep with their parents either in the
same bed or in the same Hut there was no
privacy children see their parents
having sex in the Trobriand Islands
Malinowski bushes and researcher was
told that parents took no special
precautions to prevent their children
from watching them having sex they just
scolded the child and told it to cover
its head with a mat well I think about I
remember watching Dances with Wolves and
there's that there's that scene with the
all they had was a rug a bearskin well a
bearskin coat of some sort a bearskin
I'll just leave it at that a bearskin
covered their bearskin right but there
were other people in the in the room all
right well you're gonna tell him to
leave and Iram there was a similar scene
in Vikings do you remember that mm-hmm
yeah where it was like um well a guy
that won in the memory bank is what was
the kids the kid was in the room the
personal DVR that I keep in my head
don't you welcome that and it seems odd
I mean I don't even and this seems first
of all we acknowledge that this seems a
little bit nuts right to us because we
have room like you most people have
their own room and we and we'll talk
about why we feel the way that we do do
you send Barbara out I put Barbara in
her crate but as I don't cinch it out of
you yeah she has a view from the crate
but she doesn't watch you send Jade out
no is she in a crate no is she in the
bed no she's on the floor no
where is she that she's on the couch but
your dog can't jump onto the bed no my
dog can oh yeah my dog so my dog has to
be confined when I put Jade somewhere
she stays there like she doesn't jump on
the better off the bed it's a wiener dog
thing for their back but the idea
she learns a lot but the height that she
can't apply and neither can Barbara said
although Barbara learned a lot at doggie
daycare but first of all she's a female
dog second of all she's been spayed is
that the right one for female dogs fixed
and but she learned something from some
buddies at the place where they stay
because we got her this little stuffed
dog that actually looks a lot like
Barbara and she humps it Wow
what what is the what is the canine
psychology of a she's like I've seen my
buddies doing this let's see how it is
she doesn't know what she's doing she's
just she's just doing hip gyrations but
you don't have to do it well no one
knows that I did that except those who
watched on video and I didn't really do
that it went like this
anyway so you can't learn a lot your dog
is learning a lot that's all I'm saying
just depending on how much you're
gyrating so but the one thing I wouldn't
that be embarrassing if you're like we
have friends over and it's like what is
your dog doing over there it's like
imitating me oh that's ha ha ha that's
the special that's this that's a
patented move that I thought only oh
gosh
she's see we're very I mean it's
interesting what's happening now we're
being so public with something so
private our wives would probably kill us
well people feel she's making people
feel uncomfortable is yeah we're just
making if you fell uncomfortable right
now
that's that's that's on you because we
used to be hunter-gatherers that fact it
was just a it was just part of exists
and now we live in a place where exist
you got it you got to make sure that the
doors locked cuz god forbid your kids
walking on you and all of a sudden their
lives are ruined because they see the
way that they were made really I mean
that's the way we think about it now and
that is a distinctly modern
understanding of privacy but don't act
like you wouldn't
feel weird if they obviously feel weird
because I'm a product of modern society
okay speaking of that exactly medieval
times which is not that long ago
newlyweds climbed into bed before the
eyes of family and friends and the next
day exhibit the sheets as proof that the
marriage had been consummated that is
from George's doobie editor of a history
of private life I think that was less
about privacy and more about something
else like something about consummation
there was probably like some sort of
legal ramifications of that that like
that was that was actually what marriage
made regardless of the reason for the
the practice was and there's actually a
painting associated with this particular
quote in this article it basically shows
a couple in the bed and now they did
have like the sheets the the curtains
around the bed but then the family was
all standing outside the bed and then a
couple is getting ready to do it in the
bed again individual beds are a modern
invention for most of history it wasn't
uncommon for there to be one large bed
not most most of history there wasn't a
bed but since there's been beds it
wasn't uncommon for there to be one
large bed where everyone slept that
includes the entire family some servants
and even guests where else you gonna
sleep we've got a bed and I don't
necessarily know what all was going on
in the bed but this idea of personal
space and privacy is something that was
not natural in fact the way that Greg
puts it is transparency is humanity's
natural state what's the weirdest
bedding down situation you've ever been
in probably to sharing a bed with you
know a friend at a hotel
I finally we we've had to do that and
that in desperate times led to many
altercations yeah we have different
sleeping styles
I sleep with reckless abandon as I have
gone on record insane and when I sleep
by myself I go all over the place but
when I sleep and when I sleep being in
bed with my wife I kind of go all the
place when I slept in a bed with you
you're like a rotten law just
stay completely still no contact it was
like and it's like you would
subconsciously just stay with me the
entire night we don't do that anymore
we're that successful that's right we
get our own rooms that's why we do this
so we can travel and have our own rooms
that's where we have ads however in
spite of this I think what you're
arriving at is disturbing but keep going
there seem to be some instinct all
instinctual or instinctive preference
for privacy so it wasn't uncommon for
people to choose to have sex outdoors
and I realize we're talking about having
sex a lot but I think that that is the
most intimate thing that you can do in
the continent and the presence of other
people so that's why Greg used it quite
a bit to help illustrate privacy he's
all still a freak people choosing to
have sex key D key outdoors rather than
in the same room if possible soand
Dances with Wolves if it wasn't too cold
you might go outside but that doesn't
mean a dance with the wolf you know it
doesn't mean that you're not they didn't
choose to not have sex like I think that
in certain situations okay for instance
let's just say that you and I don't and
I'm gonna quit using us and our wives as
examples just for the reason you pointed
out earlier I don't want to get them too
riled up too late but let's just say you
are a couple and you go on a trip with
another couple and you are in a
financial situation that necessitates
sharing a hotel room oh now you're
talking about Fargo yeah I don't really
remember the scene two double beds one
hotel room for people right and then two
couples the question for you listener is
you know are you going to abstain from
yeah Thank You pinky yes yeah most I
would go as far as to say 95% of modern
people in the Western world would say
for one night sure I mean oh yeah we're
not that do it this is the
living arrangement forever we might have
to start having a discussion and and and
purchase a bunch of earplugs and I don't
know a divider and I'm gonna I want to
over kind of rifle through a few of this
few of these things just to kind of
quickly catch us up to modern society
because I think this is when the when
the conversation is very interesting so
what changed why do we think differently
about this now well so while
transparency is humanity's natural state
there has always been a preference for
privacy but there wasn't a logistical
opportunity often that makes sense yeah
so if you're if you might practically
speaking it'll be private and have your
own room you would have done it but we
didn't have that we didn't that's not
how we lived but the invention of the
printing press again this is you know
I'm sure Gregg has is drawing on a lot
of sources but this is Greg's thoughts
and I tend to agree the invention of the
printing press lay the foundation for
privacy as it could hide behind it as it
allowed personal and private big machine
contemplation of writings most often
religious ones like the Bible however
this was an elite luxury so meaning that
having some time because they used to be
like if you were gonna be read something
and which was usually done in the
context of a religious setting there was
a public reading and you would all kind
of gather around and listen but now
we're the printing press we can take
these writings and we could go and we
can contemplate on them in private and
actually the concept of the private life
and what's going on privately again a
lot of this happen in a religious
context but there was also the concept
of confession which wasn't always a
thing but the idea that you were going
to go and confess something to priests
at least in the context of the Catholic
Church and that was an acknowledgment
that there was a private life and there
was an internal morality that needed to
be brought into public but it was this
concept of like I've got things that I'm
thinking about I've got things that I'm
reading on my own I've got time that I'm
spending alone and I'm contemplating
things and I am planning things and I
may be thinking things and I'm dealing
with things on my own and I'm gonna but
they wanted to kind of bring that
to have it dealt with but you started to
get this idea that this there is
something that I can kind of separate
but she's go into a closet you shut the
door and you talk through a screen right
at a priest about developing
understanding of infectious diseases
also necessitated private beds and
hospitals because before they had
individual Retta disease okay in
individual beds and hospitals they had
communal beds in hospitals why do it any
differently in the hospital so you
basically had a bed with a bunch of sick
people in it and they started noticing
everybody's getting sick in these beds
let's have a clean individual bed and
that's when the concept of the
individual bed really started to take
off for a lot for a lot of people but
then it starts to enter into writing and
thought and again this is incredibly
recent this is like literally less than
a second ago in in you know the timeline
of Kingdom of existence the Industrial
Revolution pushed it even further so
basically the material and moral
well-being of workers depend the health
of the public and the security of
society depend on each families living
in a separate healthy and convenient
home which it may purchase and this is a
speaker at the 1876 international
hygiene Council or hygiene Congress in
Brussels which is one of my favorite
historical events so that was when they
started saying everybody should have
their own house which led to everybody
should have their own room in the house
which is a kind of a later concept you
kind of started getting that in like 40s
50s like post-war 60s and of course now
you got to have your own TV in your room
right and then finally with the webcam
that's watching you and then you get rid
of you relinquish all your privacy again
full circle but it's exactly where we're
going in the final thing that until we
get up to kind of where we're at now the
legal concept of the right to privacy in
the Harvard Law Review in 1890 it was
written the intensity and complexity of
life attended upon advancing
civilization have rendered necessary
some retreat from the world and man
under the refining influence of culture
has become more sensitive to publicity
so that solitude and privacy have become
more essential to the individual but
enterprise and invention have through
invasions upon his privacy subjected him
to mental pain and distress far greater
than could be inflicted by mere bodily
injury so this was the beginning of the
recognition that a violation of privacy
is a true finally got to stand for our
right to privacy because as we begin to
introduce modern enterprise and
invention they begin to invade privacy
but there's another thing about us as
humans not only is so transparency is
the natural state but we began to fall
in love with privacy because when we can
make the choice to choose privacy we
will do it as has been demonstrated by
history but we have a problem we value
convenience over privacy so obviously
you've got modern examples of just like
choosing to do online banking and stuff
like that and and that that brings me to
I mean the time article I was reading
details what research is called the
privacy paradox which is we care so much
about our privacy yet we keep giving our
information away and it says we do it
because we reason that our future self
will probably suffer no consequences we
figure that the worst that will likely
happen is we feel kind of violated by
all the corporate algorithms and maybe
the government tracking us along with
everything else but it's worth it
because we get to use the app or we get
to buy the thing so quickly or we get to
enjoy the entertainment or we get to
connect with people or we get to share
something and get boosted in our ego
zone in a digital sphere you know I mean
while the so it's it's not the we care
about it but it's it's we care about
convenience connectivity dot a lot more
and the people who have all the money
and all the power the corporations they
know that this is the way that we are
and that's why God is data they continue
to give us
the conveniences and they continue to to
whatever degree we can talk about what
the degree is track us and listen to us
and understand the things that we like
and that we search for to begin to
develop a profile of us as individuals
so they can then turn around and sell
stuff to us according to CBS News
article Google has said it has access to
quote quoting Google 70% of credit and
debit card transactions in the United
States according to the author of one
study again this is still the CBS News
article
google has trackers on 76% of websites
while Facebook watches us on 23% of
sites and you can visit that's about six
or nine months old this article and who
knows how much that's changing day to
day but it gives you an indication of
how much how much is being tracked well
and so and you can download you can
actually find both Facebook and Google
provide ways for you to do this you can
find out everything that these companies
know about you and I read an article
where a guy explains how to do it and he
I think from Google a at a hundred and
fifty gigs of information now
interestingly and we've talked to our
friend who knows a lot about these
issues explain to us that Apple has a
very different approach to privacy they
need a Facebook Facebook or Google and
as a result the return that you'll get
from Apple when you find out what they
know about you and again on how to do
that but you can figure it out it's like
but for him it was a page it's just a
page now and it's interesting because
Apple is as chosen to say at least thus
far that we're going to respect your
privacy more and obviously via the FBI
that has been a obviously they would be
more successful maybe it was the CIA no
they would be more successful as a
company they'd have a higher profit if
they were taking advantage of the
information that's out there but before
we and I will add one more thing because
we
we're all starting to have this
experience of you have a conversation
and then you get an ad and you're like
okay they are my phone is listening to
my conversations and in it it just is
uncanny even though they will say that
they don't yeah because I mean Google
said we do not use ambient sound from
any device to target ads this is still
the CBS News article Facebook had
previously said we show ads based on
people's interest and other profile
information not what you're talking out
loud about there are sites though there
are apps that do listen and you can
control what the microphone on your
device is is allowed is allowing access
to but your money people who they don't
even need to do it there's so that would
be so much data if they were constantly
listening they don't have to do that
that the computers are so smart with all
of your just your digital footprint that
it can predict things that you want and
what and and know so much about your
your spending and your salary Instagram
where you are Instagram you listen they
don't need to listen in but it's just a
testimony to how effective they are that
you're convinced that they're listening
yeah and maybe I'm wrong but I don't
even I'm I think I'm right in it and I
think that's a stronger point that they
know that much and they're not even
listening to the audio but that's even
scarier but they I mean but their
devices like Alexa or they are listening
I mean I don't know they're doing what
they say publicly they said they're not
storing it yeah yeah I'm all I'm saying
is that we don't really know but we know
that a lot of information about us as
individuals is out there and it is being
used to them to then sell things back to
and let's not forget the government you
know I'm not I'm not one to let's not
forget it I'm not one to I just wanna
there's a lot of people that would say
that at this point so you know you can
get worked up about Facebook and Google
but don't forget about the government
themselves that's not something I found
myself personally thinking I
I have this default trust but again I
think for me as I hinted to at the
beginning I value convenience and you
know I scroll down scroll down just to
click accept on the terms and conditions
on anything that I've already convinced
that I got to have in my life and
everybody does I buy cameras and then
realize I become a peeping tom for
goodness sakes you know it's it's just
I'm being facetious that that you know
but I am NOT a peeping tom well let's
get let's get back to that because ok
you being a peeping tom no backing up
just a little bit this is not a modern
concept like there were some examples in
Greg's article about us beginning to out
of convenience sort of say oh give me a
privacy is not that important post cards
you know post cards invented in the
early twentieth century people started
using them like crazy and they would
write very personal and intimate things
on these things that could be read by
the mailman or anyone who happened to
see the post card party lines you know
before there was individual telephone
lines there were party lines where you
basically had a phone for the community
and you had to trust that your neighbors
were not listening to you and they were
listening to you all the time because I
get to do is pick the phone up
it was just like listening to your
sister talk to her boyfriend it was so
easy to do but it wasn't just confined
to a house it was within a community we
we have been willing to have intimate
conversations via text and via our
voices even knowing that we could be
listening to listen to it's not a modern
invention so as soon as we began to
value privacy it was being eroded and it
was being attacked and now with
obviously what's happened with the
internet it's just been accelerated to
the point where in fact a guy named Sam
Altman who is the loped co-founder who's
a guy who pioneered paid geolocation
services he said the magic age is people
born after 1981 that's the cut offer for
us where we see a big change in privacy
settings and user acceptance so meaning
looser privacy settings and more
acceptance of just willy nilly just
letting it into the
ether yeah now we have a pretty high
level of paranoia and skepticism we're
born I mean I was born in 77 year born
in 78 so we're before the cutoff but be
given what we do for a living and given
our personalities which is a very high
value of yeah we simulate a much younger
age I'd say I tend to be a proponent of
my brother-in-law has historically been
very concerned about his privacy when it
comes to like online banking I remember
having a conversation with him like 15
years ago where he was making the
transition to online making because it
was still something that was happening
yeah any was just I just don't feel
comfortable with it it seems like
anybody could get I was like but here's
the thing there's safety in numbers it's
inevitable we're all doing it you can't
really function in modern society
without doing it yeah your hand is
forced and so then you bet and then just
recently his his son is is applying for
college and apparently there is a new
service that allows you to create one
account and then basically make your
applications to a bunch of schools at
the same time as opposed to do what we
did which was like hand write to the few
schools that you wanted to apply to but
you want to go to 15 different schools
or apply right and it required my nephew
putting in the birthday and social
security number of both parents and of
course himself and and my brother-in-law
was like I I'm not comfortable with this
and again I said the same thing I was
like you know what anybody who wants
your social security number and birthday
who's motivated to get it can get it so
you and if you want to keep your kid out
college then that's on you
you know it's like again your hand is
forced and you have to make the decision
so he had to do it right of course he
did it
you made him feel a little bit better
about it I just said just have a credit
monitoring service here's like just make
sure you have that I feel like well I
don't have anything to hide but if you
go back to but it's that moment that
your husband comes over the webcam is
like hey that all of a sudden you have
this feeling of how long have you been
watching me that's you know it's it it
ain't feels like a violation now
you've made an argument a historical
argument that its cultural is what I
hear you saying are it's in our
Constitution our preocupes that an
inalienable right uh well maybe but ok
let's talk about this I I just wanted I
my specific question is in tracing
privacy yeah where you make an argument
that it's just cultural and that we need
to get over it because and I'll just go
ahead and state everything and you can
you can you can revisit any part you
want I have this sense that you know I I
just I just can't worry about this stuff
where our hands are being forced but if
I am gonna worry about something it's
not to me it's not the government and
many people argue we'll that's a big
mistake or it's not Google or Facebook
or fill in the blank with whoever other
corporation it is and other people say
well that's a big mistake but it's the
people who are going to the bad guys who
are gonna steal it and you stuff but I'm
like even then what's the worst that can
happen so I'm just like I just don't
want to worry about it I want to live my
life give me the chip
give me the pill whatever it is you're
willing to take the chip which is which
is happening in pretty pretty
significant numbers in Sweden at this
point right so it's not I don't want to
talk about the chip per se but you know
it's like and maybe you can go even
further into the future but again so
that's where I'm at drill in anywhere
you want your post 1981 for all intents
and purposes but are you making so did
you make the argument argument just get
over it
are you with me I'm not well here's what
I'll say in some weird
it's just crazy right transparency is
the default state the natural state of
humanity meaning that we don't have
privacy naturally or a desire for
privacy to the extent that we do now but
modern invention led to the development
of a preoccupation
with privacy that then further
advancement in a very short period of
time a hundred and fifty years led to
the essential complete evisceration of
privacy and we are all Sark in some
weird world returning back to a state of
transparency in the modern world and I
think this is where we're going
ultimately sex in front of our children
exactly this all comes down to having
sex in front of your kids and you should
go ahead and just start doing it now to
embrace the future no that's not exactly
what I always go he's a fair rug please
I think this is rare skin I think this
is where we're going you know again I
don't know what the timeline for this is
but I think we are going to a place the
technology is leading us to a place and
literate in literally the technology
will lead us in one point we've talked
about that before to a place of constant
surveillance constant surveillance that
makes 1984 Orwell's book look like
child's play the movie with Chucky which
should be which would be a great collab
but we're getting into a place where not
only where we're gonna be being 1984
starring Ryan Gosling and that puppet
from Chucky not only are we gonna be in
a place where we're being monitored by
cameras but we're gonna be being
monitored everything down to our
thoughts right I mean it's student I
don't know it I don't know when this is
gonna happen but basically all that's
happening in our brain is some
electromagnetic signaling and we can't
really figure it out yet but we will be
able to at some point not in our
lifetime but it will happen
I don't believe I believe that the brain
is so complex that that will never
happen I mean I before before it all
implodes on itself okay that's a fair
argument that we that we we die off as a
species but but the technology is
inevitably getting to that place but it
even if that's not true it is helpful to
paint that as a worst-case scenario and
then like how bad is it so well going we
are moving we are essentially moving to
a place where we are
and organism right which interestingly
is where we started from an organism
that we all came from and we're going
back to a place where like a beehive we
and again this is absolutely makes your
skin crawl is it should if you're a
healthy person the idea of being in a
place where ultimately your thoughts are
not even your own but they're being
shared and directed by a collective of
intelligence that's not even limited to
humans I mean read some Asimov and you
get to a place where it's just crazy
that he was able to talk about all this
in the 50s but basically this is where
the the technology leads us now there's
gonna be rebellions against this right
there's already people who are like I
ain't getting the chip you know there's
the matrix right yeah there's all these
examples of the the people rebelling
against it and that's probably a healthy
thing and there will be rebellions but
the general trajectory unless we destroy
ourselves which is very likely that we
will destroy ourselves let's just for
argument's sake say that we won't
destroy ourselves the the general
trajectory is towards a place of us
becoming an organism an individualism is
a super like American thing right now
and we're all excited about it we want
to defend it we were willing to fight
and die for it right now and that's
great all I'm saying is it's temporary
and it's not even a natural thing when
it comes to humans it's just something
that was an anomaly a blip on the radar
of existence that happened because of
some technology that got existed that
got that brought into existence I think
that's the probably the the biggest
contribution of the self-driving car is
how it will be a big cultural shift of
acceptance of community hmm well I have
a wild one last wild theory
I believe I'm kind of on the Elon Musk
team here in thinking that statistically
speaking we're probably in a simulation
we've talked about this before if we're
in a simulation and the inevitable
trajectory of the simulation is that we
are getting to a place in which we
recognize that we're all one organism
it's all data and it's being controlled
experienced in exchange as a collective
at that point we basically become
indistinguishable indistinguishable from
the computer that is powering the
simulation that we're in which is all
based on data all right I haven't read
this theory anywhere I'm sure somebody
else has come up with it but at that
point once you're this collective and
you're just kind of existing in the
world of data that is essentially a
computer hard drive and at that point
when we get to that place in this
indistinguishable the simulation is
indistinguishable from the computer that
is making the simulation happen that is
when we will be delivered that is when
we will be delivered as a species
delivered we will get out of the
simulation I know me and you tried to do
it one time I used to think that maybe
just admitting that it was a simulation
and holding hands with your best friend
was how you got out of the simulation we
two guys are linked and read and we know
we are in a simulation and we want out
now that didn't work cuz we tried it we
tried it many times since then let's not
try that again but now I'm beginning to
think that your head against the wall
instead it's just a recognition it's not
a recognition it is an assimilation into
the actual data that is making up the
simulation you have to become the data
and once you become the data you break
out of the simulation that is that we
did electively transform into an wheeler
distant future an 18-wheeler yeah we
could also just destroy ourselves and
take our turn like a chance that the
simulation ends at that point
but I don't want to take that chance so
we are you in it to win it so I guess
what I'm saying is wind well I guess
whatever I see be damned temporarily you
you're doing it for that you do that for
the singularity I'm not going to watch
my family and friends because it makes
them feel uncomfortable but in the back
of my mind I know that everyone's gonna
be watched eventually I'll let it come
when it's inevitable but I'm not going
to usher it in and I might be part of
the resistance I'm not saying that I'm
not gonna be part of the resistance
because Morpheus is really cool cool
switch turned on you're like well hold
on actually it might be cooler to be on
the other side so I might be part of the
resistance
okay I saw what it have it yeah yeah
yeah right whatever is the cool whatever
is the best experience for me man you
know it just selfish at this point I'm
putting it on you hashtag ear biscuits
let us know and you know what what what
I don't want you to do is just rip me a
new one for what I for being a peeping
tom okay it's like I yeah I'm gonna I'm
uh slow my roll and as a family we're
gonna we're gonna put some ground rules
in place and then we're gonna we're
gonna put a we're gonna we're gonna have
our own so to speak placard on our door
I'm just saying that I'm not really if
you want to talk to me about it that's
fine but I that what I just said my
piece but then the larger question of
how how I am curious how you relate to
these issues of privacy hash tag ear
biscuits let us know yeah the
conversation must continue and we will
be listening
[Music]